when you wrote the brilliant album
harvest this is crazy to me tell me if
this is true after you wrote the album
you said to nash i want you to hear the
album you took him out in a row boat you
played him the album on one side of the
lake you were on was uh
your barn and you had a big speaker in
the barn for the let's say the right
hand sound and on the left hand you had
some other structure where you had
a speaker a house a house a house and
you're there and you're playing him this
masterpiece you've written and you're
hearing it and you go you yell out to
your people
give me more barn
there wasn't enough sound coming out of
the barn well i just wanted to hear what
it was you know stereo
i just wanted to hear a bigger bigger
stereo
and you know i had these big voices of
the theater speakers set up
in in both buildings and and uh wires
running from one to the other
it was before internet and all that
stuff and uh
and uh yeah we were on in the row boat a
little aluminum row boat on the lake
that's in front of my house and also the
barn is on the other side of the lake by
about maybe you know 150 yards
so we're sitting there and that
it's maybe 300 yards or 250 yards
between the barn and the house
and i'm in the middle more or less
a little bit closer to the house
and we needed more barn to me it was
like
more barn
when you added the barn and now you're
in a boat
and you're playing them this
[Music]
did you hear how great crosby's voice
was in alabama and that chorus is
amazing is that crosby on that that's
crosby and stills
wow
every song on it is good a man needs a
maid old man needle and the damage done
when you played that for graham sitting
in that boat was he just floored well he
heard it like you know first of all
that overdubs that we did i think we did
words and we did other things too i
played and he already we already i i
can't remember if i was playing this
forum after we'd done the overdubs
i think i was right i wouldn't be
sitting there listening to the whole
album in a boat if it wasn't finished
i can't i can't waste listens that's a
wasted listen i can't listening is like
gold
i only listen
if i have to and i only listen for a
reason and when everything's done i'll
listen to it that's all gas smokes and
we can listen to it while i'm taking a
walk but if i'm working on it
a listen is like gold do you ever go
back and listen to your old albums
ever only just just in in the archives
we're searching for things that's it
we're looking for now we got this thing
called fresh tracks
that we're listening for yeah it's a
version of the song that shows something
that was lost
on the search for perfection
and
as we were trying to make the finished
record we went by
the essence of the record and left it
behind
and that was our dmo at the time was to
make the perfect record you don't make a
great record we were over dubbing i was
doing things like that at that time
um
but now i find these
i find these originals fresh tracks
first time i ever played it
never anywhere in the archive is there
an earlier version nice and there's one
album of that that's coming out in the
next archives that i wanted to tell you
about
and volume 3 which has 13 discs in it
wow and the last disc is called summer
songs
and that's a uh
it's all these original songs that i did
but they're all two years at least
before the records came out
you